as I said here in the middle of February
we're about eight months away from
Election Day 2016 doesn't that sound
completely insane I mean think about it
we've been talking about this election
for at least a year and we're still over
half a year away from it that is
completely bonkers so much of the
election process is just inside or
nonsense and day-to-day PR so it's hard
to focus on what issues are actually
important not only does the 24-hour
cable news cycle thrive on election
drama and distractions but the entire
process of electing our politicians
seems to be built on getting we the
people to actually never talk about the
big issues in an honest way we have
debates with catered questions no actual
debating we've town halls which are just
forums for talking points and social
media campaigns to spread candidates
messages without ever explaining how
their ideas will actually solve anything
you know there's a strange collusion
between the media and politicians to
keep us all in the dark about what's
really going on here what I actually
want to hear candidates talking about
our big ideas not political talking
points to explain their economic
philosophy and how it came to be to say
how they came up with a moral argument
for or against abortion and to let us
know why America's role in the world
should be larger or smaller
unfortunately big ideas don't fit into
30-second sound bites leaving us with a
media that wants views and clicks
instead of substantive debate and a
political class who of course are all
the happier to provide meaningless
slogans that sound good in a headline
but don't mean anything at all that
brings me to the two people really
shaking up the system at this point
Bernie Sanders and Donald Trump Bernie
says he wants a political revolution
while Trump says he wants to make
America great again I doubt they'll ever
be another candidate like Bernie a
world-weary lifelong politician who
wants to fundamentally change how things
operate from the inside whether you
agree or disagree with him it's a
powerful message that of course there is
Trump a billionaire who's using years of
boardroom and TV experience to give his
supporters whatever they want even if
they don't know exactly what that is
what these two men have in common though
is more interesting they both openly
mock the powerful and corrupting
influence of money in politics while
only existing is legitimate contenders
because of its very existence it
shouldn't be lost on us that it's
actually the very strength of our
democratic system that allows two people
who want to totally up end it to be
surging in the polls and as warped as
our system is is the two guys who are
the most plain-spoken who are being
heard the loudest although the countdown
to election 2016 frustrates me as a
political junkie i cant pretend that I
don't enjoy the clown show it's a soap
opera with characters you just can't
make up I mean we've got the
ex-presidents wife the socialist jus the
billionaire in the neurosurgeon it
basically sounds like spinoff of
Gilligan's Island unfortunately while
Gilligan and his friends were eventually
rescued from their Island the only ones
who can rescue us from this shipwreck
are ourselves the citizens to help me
navigate these choppy waters this week
as my guest Ben Shapiro the
editor-at-large of Breitbart com many of
you have asked us to have a sit-down to
dig into some of his conservative ideas
can a liberal in a conservative coexist
well if Thurston Howell the third and
ginger could do it I have a feeling that
Ben and I will be able to as well every
election year politicians remind us that
their election is the most important of
a generation usually that's just more
hyperbole nonsense but this time it
could actually be true regardless of who
wins whether it's one of these two
Hillary or Jeb or the skipper our system
is fundamentally shaking right now as
evidenced by both the Sanders and Trump
surges can we address real issues in the
months to come or will we keep talking
about sideshow nonsense can we get a
fairer election system or will big
donors always run the show can we elect
officials who will compromise to make
the country stronger or will partisan
points always win the day these are just
a few of the huge issues we have to
discuss and that's not even touching on
immigration healthcare and terrorism a
lot of people mock the idea of American
exceptionalism especially on the left
but I actually do believe in it there
has never been a country in the history
of the globe that has taken more people
from across the world and help them make
a better life for themselves their
children and their children's children
even now with all of our problems people
still want to come to
America for a better life we have
massive issues but underneath it all
there's a bedrock based in democratic
principles which still makes our
position in the world truly unique it
doesn't mean America can or should tell
the world what to do but it does mean we
have a responsibility to be fairer freer
and more functional whenever we can all
these reasons are why I've made the show
about ideas and not my new show there is
an endless cycle of noise designed to
keep us distracted and divided our
politicians will only be better if we
demand they be better we'll only demand
our politicians be better if we are
better ourselves as you guys know I love
to say the two things can be true at the
same time maybe we can have a political
revolution while at the same time making
America great again this change doesn't
start with Trump and Sanders though it
starts with the government of the people
by the people and for the people just as
the great Gilligan once said